ya hablamos de como la estructura del
adn de doble hélice de escalera torcida
le permite ser la molécula base de la
herencia pero lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es brindar una mejor
apreciación de por qué es adecuada y
explicar el mecanismo que la hace la
molécula base de la herencia nos vamos a
enfocar en un nivel conceptual ojo no
voy a entrar en los detalles bioquímicos
el objetivo es darte una idea conceptual
de lo que sucede entonces esto de aquí
podría ser un fragmento de adn tengo
estos 12 3 6 8 8 pares de bases
dibujadas y sólo para aclarar hablé de
esto en el vídeo de adn el adn es más
que un puñado de pares de bases la
molécula del adn puede ser miles de
millones de pares de bases por ejemplo
esta de aquí puede ser la molécula del
adn puede ser de miles de millones de
pares de bases o inclusive esta puede
ser una sección del adn mucho más grande
e incluso me dibujo puede que no le esté
haciendo justicia pero bueno este
y puede ser la ampliación de una pequeña
muy pequeña sección de la hebra
imagínate en esta pequeña sección y esta
es la ampliación de esa hebra así que lo
voy a poner así para que veas que es una
ampliación y de nuevo puede ser que esta
sea una pequeña sección de una molécula
que ojo no tiene ocho pares de bases
sino tiene 70 millones de pares de bases
o más entonces veamos qué
características necesita tener una
molécula de la herencia y bueno lo
primero que necesita va a ser a ser
replicable ser capaz de replicarse
cuando una célula se divide a las dos
nuevas células les gustaría tener el
mismo material genético no entonces cómo
se duplica el adn bueno a este proceso
se le conoce con el nombre de
replicación déjame ponerlo aquí
lin
vamos a ver la replicación del adn y
agua si hablamos en el vídeo
introductorio recuerdas pero lo que
quiero ver aquí son los diferentes
procesos al mismo tiempo así que vamos a
hablar de la replicación y bueno para
eso lo que voy a hacer es agarrar la
mitad de esta escalera y con ella
tenemos que ser capaces de construir la
otra mitad de la escalera así que de
hecho déjame hacer lo voy a atrapar la
primera mitad déjame ponerlo así voy a
atrapar la primera mitad déjame copiarla
y voy a pegarlo por acá así que ya tengo
esta otra mitad que es nuestra primera
mitad nuestro lado izquierdo déjame
ponerla justo por aquí ok y ahora voy a
hacer lo mismo con el lado derecho voy a
tomar el lado derecho de esta molécula
ok vamos a copiarla apagarla y bueno
ahora que lo tengo aquí lo voy a poner
más o menos por lo voy a poner más o
menos por acá ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es replicar este adn y cómo lo vamos a
hacer bueno si tengo el lado izquierdo o
el lado derecho de esta escalera con
esta misma información voy a hacer
de lograr obtener la otra información y
con ello vamos a tener dos hebras
idénticas de adn y esto es a partir de
la información que ya tenemos aquí
porque recuerda que la am siempre se une
con la te recuerdas la adenina siempre
se une con la timina así que aquí voy a
poner te hace una corte aquí también voy
a poner te hace una corte y aquí también
voy a poner una de la a siempre se une
con la tf y bueno la timina siempre se
une con la adenina así que aquí voy a
poner una de hacerlo un poco más claro
antes de poner aquí una a perfecto
bueno aquí voy a poner también otra
látex una cola y la guanina siempre se
une con la citosina así que aquí voy a
poner una c y aquí voy a poner una c y
la citosina siempre se une con la
guanina por lo tanto voy a poner aquí
una g ahora date cuenta que con sólo el
lado izquierdo logramos obtener también
el lado derecho así que déjenme poner
ahora con color amarillo
el nuevo esqueleto
esta nueva hebra de adn que es la unión
de azúcar y fosfato recuerdas la unión
de azúcar y fosfato y también voy a
hacer lo mismo con el otro lado con el
lado derecho
recuerda que sabemos que la timina
siempre se une con la adenina así que
déjame ponerlo de una vez la timina se
une con la adenina esto va a quedar así
la timina se une siempre con la adenina
con la adenina la del inah con la timina
así que lo voy a poner así la de mina
con la timina laden y la con la timina
la citosina con la guanina así que aquí
voy a poner una g g con cm
g con c y por lo tanto aquí me falta una
c la c se une con la g
por lo tanto puedes tomar cualquier lado
de la escalera y reconstruir el otro
lado la otra mitad y lo que
esencialmente acabamos de hacer es
replicar el adn y todo esto fue un
ejemplo conceptual de cómo se realiza la
replicación antes de que las células se
dividan y se duplique entonces esto fue
la replicación la replicación y
ahora vamos a hablar de la expresión
porque seguramente estás pensando ok
esto de que se pueda replicar está muy
bien pero sería algo sin utilidad si la
información no se puede usar para
definir al organismo para expresar lo
que está pasando así que pensemos en los
genes en el adn y cómo se expresan and
déjame ponerlo aquí vamos a hablar de la
expresión expresión y estos conceptos
pueden tener varios significados por eso
voy a tratar de explicar poco a detalle
qué son cada uno de estos conceptos así
que vamos a hablar un poco de que es un
cromosoma que es el adn y qué es un gen
y cómo están claramente relacionados
vale la pena saber que es que cuando
hablamos de adn
estamos hablando literalmente de esta
molécula de aquí de esta doble hélice
que está formada por azúcar fosfato y
base y tiene la secuencia de pares de
bases recuerdas tiene una estructura de
doble hélice y toda esta hebra podría
ser una molécula
ahora cuando tienes una molécula de adn
empaquetada con otras moléculas y
proteínas formando una estructura más
grande entonces tenemos un cromosoma ojo
y cuando hablamos de un gen hablamos de
una sección del adn que se utiliza para
expresar cierta característica o de
hecho se utiliza para codificar una
cierta proteína por ejemplo pueda tomar
el color naranja y decir que esta parte
esta parte de la hebra es un gen porque
calificaría para alguna cierta proteína
puede tener la información de un gen o
bueno de hecho podríamos pensar en a ver
tomemos otro color esta otra sección
puede expresar se puede expresar a otro
gen porque calificaría para otra
proteína y los genes pueden ser en
cualquier lugar pueden ser de varios de
miles de pares de bases o pueden llegar
hasta millones de pares de pases y como
veremos la manera en que se expresa un
gen es decir la manera en que obtenemos
la información a partir de esta sección
del adn para codificar una proteína es a
través de una molécula de relación
al adn es decir vamos a hablar del a rn
y déjame escribir por aquí el a
en rn significa ácido ribonucleico
déjame ponerlo aquí
ribonucleico rin
clay co ribonucleico como seguramente
recuerdas que significa adn es decir
ácido desoxirribonucleico entonces
claramente te vas a dar cuenta de que
tenemos un azúcar en el esqueleto del
adn es una molécula muy parecida a la
del adn pero ahora está oxigenada no es
de extorsivo nucleico es ribonucleico es
más lo voy a hacer más claro adn
efe
n proviene la a de ácido de ácido la r
derribo y la n de nucleicos por la misma
razón que teníamos la n en el adn
entonces qué papel juega este a rn en
todo lo que tenemos aquí bueno pues
particularmente el adn se encuentra en
el núcleo pero la mayor parte de su
información debe salir del núcleo para
ser expresada y una de las funciones que
tiene el adn es ser ese mensajero ese
mensajero de una cierta sección del adn
que sale del núcleo para ser traducido a
una proteína y el paso de ir del adn al
aire en el mensajero se les llama
transcripción así que déjenme ponerlo
aquí atrás
escribe
sión y qué sucede en esta transcripción
bueno primero regresemos a ver un poco
sobre cómo se comportaba esta molécula
del adn así que digamos que tenemos esta
sección de aquí y es más déjeme de
copiar solamente la mitad
voy a atrapar y copiar la mitad ok
justo como lo hicimos en el proceso de
replicación voy a copiar y pegar justo
aquí ya está la voy a poner aquí en la
parte de transcripción déjame ponerlo
justo aquí pero ahora no queremos
duplicar la molécula del adn recuerda
queremos crear su molécula de rn
mensajero correspondiente al menos para
esa sección o para este fin o parte
defiende nuestra molécula de adn lo que
quiero hacer es la transcripción y es
una idea bastante similar pero ahora
vamos a construir una hebra de rn
específicamente de rn mensajero porque
éste sacara la información del núcleo
este proceso es muy similar al de
replicación a excepción de que cuando se
trata de hacer
en la adenina déjame ponerlo así con
este color la adivina en esta ocasión se
va a unir no a la timina sino al ahora
sí lo ahora laden y la se va a unir al
brasil o brasil o al brasil o el a rn
tiene un asilo en lugar de timina pero
ojo seguir atendiendo que la guanina las
citocinas seguirán siendo pareja así que
cómo quedaría esto bueno esta se va a
unir a un cura si lo está se va a unir a
un cura si lo está aún por asilo y
después esta tímida bueno esta termina
se va a unir también a una de nila esta
termina a una de lila estaba lila a una
citosina a 1 citosina estaban y la aún
así tocina y éstas y tocina a una
guanina y ya está pero ojo estas
moléculas que tenemos aquí se pueden
separar y así tener sólo una hebra de rn
una hebra de la parte derecha de esto
que estoy poniendo justo aquí que en
este caso sería
en el mensajero es decir tiene toda la
información de esta sección de adn y
después esta molécula puede salir del
núcleo y unirse a un ribosoma y
hablaremos exactamente de cómo sucede en
futuros vídeos pero bueno este código
también puede ser utilizado para
codificar proteínas y como sucede esto
bueno con un proceso que se llama
traducción déjame ponerlo aquí
traducción y en qué consiste este
proceso de traducción bueno consiste en
tomar una secuencia de los pares de las
bases y convertirla en más secuencia de
aminoácidos y las proteínas están hechas
por secuencias de aminoácidos así que lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
fijarnos en nuestro adn mensajero que
tenemos aquí o bueno nuevos en esta
pequeña sección de aire en el mensajero
que tenemos aquí déjame ponerla por acá
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es pasar esta
misma información pero de manera
horizontal para eso empezamos con una 1
1 1
y hace entonces empezamos aquí con una y
después seguía una a una se después otra
u después otra y después una hay una sea
así que déjame ponerlo con su respectivo
color aquí voy a tener una am aquí voy a
tener otra am
aquí nos falta una c así que voy a
ponerla aquí nos falta otra c y si
recuerdas al final teníamos una guanina
esta guanina que tengo aquí que la voy a
poner justo por aquí y bueno esta
información puede seguir y seguir y
seguir y también seguir y seguir y
seguir por acá lo único que hice fue
poner esta parte de la rn mensajero pero
ahora de manera horizontal y lo que pasa
es que cada secuencia de tres bases y
cuidado tienes que ser muy cuidadoso en
donde empiezas porque esto de alguna
forma es bastante delicado en un proceso
simplemente robusto pero supongamos que
empezamos aquí cada tres de estas bases
codifica para un aminoácido específico
así que me tomo aquí 1
23 este primer conjunto de tres bases
juntas se le conoce con el nombre de
codón
después me tomo otras tres y tengo una
dos tres aquí tengo otro codón otro
codón y bueno para acabar el día 12 y
aquí no hace falta una base los citó
otras 3 tendría otro codón otro cordón y
cuántos posibles cordones tenemos bueno
tenemos una de cuatro bases así que en
este lugar tenemos una de cuatro bases
aquí tenemos una de cuatro bases aquí
otra vez una de cuatro bases y por lo
tanto tenemos tres diferentes lugares lo
que nos daría 4 x 4 x 4 4 x 4 x 4
posibles cordones y 4 x 4 x 4 de 64
entonces tenemos 64 64 cordones posibles
tú
simples y bueno esto es bastante bueno
porque tenemos 20 aminoácidos posibles
lo que permite que otros cordones
también se usen para otros propósitos o
bueno también puedes tener más de un
cordón que codifica para el mismo
aminoácido hay 64 cordones posibles y
bueno necesitamos codificar 20
aminoácidos entonces este cordón junto a
un ribosoma y hablaremos de cómo sucede
esto en un segundo puede codificar
digamos para no ser un aminoácido déjame
ponerlo aquí me voy a tomar aquí a un
aminoácido el cual le voy a poner
aminoácido 1 este va a ser mi aminoácido
1 y de hecho este aminoácido 1 es
llevado hacia acá por otro tipo de arn
son emparejados por otro tipo de arn
nosotros estamos hablando aquí del a rn
mensajeros recuerdas
r en mensajero pero hay otro tipo de
aire en el aire
es decir el aire de transferencia que
esencialmente acerca estas dos moléculas
y voy a dibujar aquí a mi aire de
transferencia va por aquí se abre va por
acá se abre y después formaría algo así
algo sigue y bueno estoy intentando
dibujarlo a lo mejor posible pero
también recuerda que aquí junto a esta
aún debemos de tener una am junto a esta
debemos de tener una 1 y al lado de esta
sede vamos a tener un agente entonces
este aminoácido se va a pegar bajo este
a rn de transferencia que tengo aquí a
este otro extremo al extremo que tiene
estas tres bases y después aquí voy a
tener dejar ponerlo así otro a el de
transferencia y otro a rn transferencia
que se va a emparejar con la otra parte
de este cordón que corresponde a una
y bueno este aire de transferencia se va
a pegar a otro aminoácido lo voy a poner
aquí este va a ser mi aminoácidos y como
te das cuenta aquí vamos construyendo
una secuencia de aminoácidos uno otro
otro otro y conforme pones estos
aminoácidos juntos estás construyendo
una proteína así que antes que me pela
por aquí por aquí tengo uno de los
aminoácidos después puedo poner aquí a
otro y después puedo poner otros más no
sé una secuencia de aminoácidos y cuando
tenemos una secuencia de aminoácidos
esencialmente lo que estamos haciendo es
construir una proteína y estas proteínas
son fundamentales para operar la vida
obviamente sabes que si tú comes a un
animal este animal contiene grasas
azúcares proteínas pero son las
proteínas las que necesitamos más pues
funcionan como enzimas funcionan de
forma estructural no sé los músculos
están hechos de proteínas y bueno ojo
solo dibuje un pequeño fragmento puedes
tener miles o más de estos aminoácidos
juntos
que su vez forman estructuras tan
complejas como las proteínas y bueno
estas tienen muchas funciones de aquí
nace el trabajo de la vida o la mayor
parte de él y bueno espero que este
vídeo te haya servido para entender un
poco mejor cómo se almacena la
información en los seres vivos